Revisore: Michele Gianella
L'ambito in cui lavoro,
per la mia attività di ricerca,
è quello della biorobotica.
La biorobotica ha l'obiettivo di studiare
da un punto di vista ingegneristico
il funzionamento dei sistemi biologici,
con l'obiettivo ultimo
di sviluppare nuovi robot,
di tipo bio-ispirati, cioè ispirati
a sistemi biologici già esistenti,
o allo sviluppo
di nuovi dispositivi biomedici.
Ed è all'interno di quest'area
che ricadono, appunto,
le interfacce neurali.
Le interfacce neurali
non sono altro che degli elettrodi,
in particolare parliamo
di interfacce neurali invasive,
cioè che vengono inserite
all'interno del sistema nervoso,
per poter mettere in comunicazione
il sistema nervoso,
a livello periferico o centrale,
con un dispositivo artificiale.
Per capire meglio dove vengono collocate,
dobbiamo sapere che il sistema nervoso
è alla base di tutto ciò
che riguarda le nostre sensazioni
e i nostri movimenti,
di tipo volontario o involontario.
E il sistema nervoso si divide,
essenzialmente, in due grandi aree:
il sistema nervoso centrale,
costituito dalla corteccia
e dal midollo spinale;
e il sistema nervoso periferico,
costituito dai nervi periferici e cranici.
Alla base del sistema nervoso,
quindi alla base della trasmissione
degli impulsi nervosi,
c'è la cellula neurale.
Quello che succede,
nel momento in cui si propaga
l'impulso nervoso,
è che su quella specie
di salsicciotto, che vedete lì,
si propaga una variazione
della differenza di potenziale
tra l'interno e l'esterno di questo,
che viene chiamato assone.
Quindi,
se siamo in grado di posizionare
la nostra interfaccia neurale
in prossimità di questo assone,
siamo in grado di percepire
l'impulso neurale.
Allora, qui ho selezionato
due principali applicazioni
per le interfacce neurali.
Sono ancora allo stato della ricerca.
Fra quelle che ho selezionato,
ne abbiamo una per l'applicazione
a livello centrale,
in particolare per la corteccia visiva,
per una paziente
che si è offerta volontaria
per questo esperimento
per una neuroprotesi visiva.
[Italiano]: La facoltà visiva sorge
da milioni di anni di evoluzione.
Nemmeno riusciamo a comprenderla, ancora,
ma oggi la tecnologia si sta avvicinando
alla complessità degli occhi umani.
Cheryl Robinson, dal Missouri,
sta per entrare in questo mondo virtuale.
Nella speranza di riconquistare la vista,
Cheryl si è offerta
per una procedura sperimentale.
I dottori le perforano entrambi i lati
del cervello, esponendole il cervello.
Poi impiantano due placche triangolari,
ciascuna delle quali ospita
200 piccoli elettrodi,
direttamente nella corteccia
visiva di Cheryl.
Infine, i chirurghi tirano i cavi
dalle placche ai terminali
attaccati all'esterno del cranio.
Dopodiché, gli elettrodi
passano attraverso un computer
a una fotocamera sugli occhiali di Cheryl.
Ma prima che lei possa vedere
ciò che vede la telecamera,
molte altre cose devono succedere.
Ogni elettrodo tocca una parte differente
del cervello di Cheryl.
E quando il sistema eccita un elettrodo,
lei vede un lampo in qualche punto
del suo campo visivo.
Dove?
I dottori non lo sanno.
"Ora?"
Perciò eccitano gli elettrodi uno a uno
per capire dove Cheryl veda i lampi
nel suo campo visivo.
"Now?"
"Oh, wow! Lì, in alto a destra" - "Ok"
Quando vede un lampo,
Cheryl punta in alto, in basso,
a destra o a sinistra.
A ogni elettrodo mappato,
i dottori connettono la fotocamera,
sincerandosi che la visione
corrisponda ai lampi
nel cervello di Cheryl.
Finalmente, ora che
la telecamera è montata,
la madre di Cheryl aiuta
a collegare il nuovo settaggio.
"Pronta?"
(Risate)
Riuscirà la tecnologia
a restituire la vista a Cheryl?
"Oh, wow!
Vedo delle grandi bandiere, lì!"
"So che c'è un oggetto, lì.
Non so di cosa si tratti.
È un'imbarcazione, quella?"
Quindi, quello che è successo
è che lei è riuscita
ad avere delle sensazioni visive.
Certo, questo è ben diverso dal dire
che ha riconquistato la vista perduta,
però la ricerca in questo senso
sta progredendo.
L'altro tipo di applicazione
riguarda, invece, un'applicazione
per il sistema nervoso periferico.
Su questo esperimento hanno lavorato
anche la Scuola Superiore Sant'Anna,
il gruppo delle interfacce neurali
della Scuola Superiore Sant'Anna,
per cui lavoro,
e questo riguarda una neuroprotesi
per un ragazzo amputato di arto superiore.
(Video): Pierpaolo,
un giovane italo-brasiliano,
accetta di fare da cavia
in nome del progresso.
La speranza è che gli elettrodi,
inseriti nei nervi recisi del braccio,
permettano di registrare le onde cerebrali
necessarie per azionare la protesi.
L'intervento consiste nell'inserire
due elettrodi nel nervo mediano,
e due in quello ulnare.
Gli elettrodi usati
sono più sottili di un capello.
Sono studiati per aderire al nervo
in modo da captare le onde cerebrali
e costituire un ponte
tra l'attività mentale di Pierpaolo
e il mondo artificiale del computer,
che dovrà decodificarle
e trasformarle in comandi.
Si tratta di una tecnica sperimentale,
studiata per permettere
punti di contatto affidabili
per le sei settimane dell'esperimento.
Al termine verranno rimossi,
in attesa che i bioingegneri sviluppino
una nuova generazione di elettrodi
per impianti permanenti.
Il computer analizza il flusso caotico
dell'attività elettrica
che arriva dal cervello.
I programmi isolano
i segnali significativi,
e poco alla volta il paziente impara
a guidare l'interfaccia meccanica.
Ubbidiente, la mano mette in pratica
i desideri di Pierpaolo,
eseguendo i movimenti desiderati.
SB: Quindi, questi che vi ho fatto vedere
sono ancora allo stato,
appunto, della ricerca
perché molti limiti ancora ci sono
per l'applicazione cronica
di queste interfacce.
Quindi la nostra attività di ricerca -
la mia e quella del gruppo
delle interfacce neurali
della Scuola Sant'Anna -
è quello di superare
alcuni di questi limiti.
Un approccio è quello di creare
un'interfaccia,
diciamo così, intelligente,
che sia in grado di adattare
il posizionamento dell'elettrodo
all'interno del tessuto dopo l'impianto.
In questo modo si può assicurare
un maggior tempo di vita,
ed una maggiore qualità
del segnale dopo l'impianto.
Un altro aspetto che stiamo studiando
è quello di ridurre l'invasività,
quindi il danno,
che andiamo a fare nel nervo
in seguito all'inserimento
dell'interfaccia,
e infine quello di ricoprire
la superficie dell'elettrodo
con un coding di tipo bi-attivo,
che aiuti a ridurre la reazione fibrotica
del tessuto attorno all'elettrodo.
In qualche modo,
questi studi hanno rivelato
che c'è anche un potenziale
che possa farci passare
da quello che era un progetto di ricerca,
ad un progetto di impresa.
Però, quando mi sono trovata
ad affrontare questo tipo di transizione,
mi sono trovata nella situazione
in cui si trovano
molti ricercatori italiani.
Si trovano davanti un muro,
che è il muro del non sapere
come affrontare le dinamiche
di un nuovo business,
di una nuova impresa.
Quindi sono incappata in questo programma
che è il Fullbright Best,
che è un programma di scambi culturali
promosso sia dall'Italia
che dagli Stati Uniti,
che ha proprio l'obiettivo
di promuovere l'imprenditoria italiana,
mandando fisicamente ricercatori come me
nel campo dell'high-tech,
mandandoli - con ovviamente
un'idea imprenditoriale,
in Silicon Valley,
per un periodo di formazione.
Perché in Silicon Valley?
Perché la Silicon Valley,
che si trova a sud di San Francisco,
concentra una serie
di elementi caratteristici.
Prima di tutto,
è qui che molte società importanti
hanno il loro quartier generale.
Parliamo di Google,
di Apple, Yahoo, E-bay.
Sono tutte concentrate
in pochi chilometri.
Oltre a queste, ci sono anche
delle università di prestigio
come Stanford, Berkeley,
o anche il centro studi della Nasa;
e in più, a completare il quadro,
c'è un folto gruppo di investitori.
Di investitori che decidono
di investire il loro denaro,
piuttosto che in titoli in borsa,
in nuove idee di impresa.
Quindi, quello che succede
è che per imparare,
per avviare una nuova società
in Silicon Valley è necessario -
se prima nella Silicon Valley
c'era la ricerca all'oro,
adesso c'è la ricerca a loro,
agli imprenditori.
Cioè cercare di convincerli,
creando un business plan,
quindi un piano di business convincente -
e soprattutto imparare a comunicarlo
ai possibili investitori.
Comunicarlo attraverso quello
che viene ormai definito, conosciuto
come "Elevator Pitch",
cioè la possibilità
di convincere un imprenditore
nell'arco di tempo che intercorre
in una corsa in ascensore
dal primo all'ultimo piano
di un grattacielo.
Quindi, parte della mia attività,
della mia formazione in Silicon Valley
è stata proprio quella di frequentare
dei corsi universitari
nella Santa Clara University,
proprio presso la scuola di business,
e poi vedere in pratica,
durante tre mesi di stage
in un'azienda locale,
come poi questi principi vengono, appunto,
messi in pratica
da una start-up del posto.
Il tutto, ovviamente,
messo insieme e amalgamato
da un'importante rete di networking,
che è necessario fare
nel momento in cui sei lì,
per poter cercare di trovare personaggi
con un'esperienza pregressa d'impresa,
che possano darti
consigli utili e importanti
per rendere la tua idea effettiva.
E in aggiunta quindi a questo poi,
ovviamente nel momento
in cui siamo in questo tipo di mondo,
uno degli eventi a cui si partecipa
è quello della Business Plan Competition,
ossia tutti questi aspiranti imprenditori
si sfidano a colpi di business plan.
Tutti questi elementi
sono stati poi convogliati
all'interno del mio
progetto imprenditoriale,
dando così vita a quello
che ho chiamato "Smania",
dove "Smania" sta per SMArt
Neural Interfaces and Advanced Modeling.
Importante è stato l'aiuto di -
l'aver conosciuto personaggi
totalmente diversi
da quelli che incontriamo qui in Italia.
Un esempio è proprio quello
di Josh McCouer,
che è un imprenditore seriale,
tipico imprenditore della Silicon Valley.
Josh McCouer,
oltre ad avere una formazione
di altissimo livello,
un MBA alla Columbia University,
ha studiato al MIT,
poi alla New York University
eccetera eccetera,
ha fondato sette o otto imprese
nel campo della biomedica.
Dico che è un imprenditore modello
della Silicon Valley,
perché non solo le ha fondate,
ma è arrivato ad un punto in cui ha fatto
quella che si chiama
"Exit Strategy" di successo.
Cioè è riuscito a vendere,
per svariate centinaia
di milioni di dollari,
molte di queste sue società
che ha fondato in pochissimi anni.
Poi, ovviamente,
molto importante è conoscere
anche altri giovani imprenditori
che sono nella tua stessa barca,
come ad esempio Elisabetta Bianchini,
con cui abbiamo cominciato
un nuovo progetto insieme,
proprio per capire e mettere insieme,
appunto, le tue idee di business.
Quindi, quello che mi aspetta ora
è ovviamente mettere in pratica
tutto quello che ho imparato
durante i miei anni di ricerca
e durante i miei anni
di formazione in Silicon Valley,
per dare vita a questo progetto
e renderlo quindi una realtà.
Ovviamente senza dimenticare
le lezioni importanti imparate proprio lì.
Una tra queste,
che mi ha colpito tra tutte,
è quella che nel momento
in cui vogliamo davvero
creare qualcosa di importante, di grande,
è importante selezionare e circondarsi
di persone in gamba, di persone brave,
volendo anche più brave di te.
Quindi non aver paura del talento,
ed evitare di cercare -
(Applausi)
di circondarsi di persone
meno brave di te.
Quindi ricordatevi che gli "A"
prendono gli "A" a collaborare con sé,
cioè le classi di talenti,
mentre i "B" prendono i "C" e così via.
Quindi ringrazio voi per l'attenzione,
e tutto il gruppo delle interfacce neurali
della Scuola Sant'Anna.
(Applausi)